[Music]
we just saw you wearing this outfit this
this incredible outfit one piece yeah
one piece and and the way you talk the
way you
you conduct yourself you seem fearless
to me you seem like you fear nothing
that's not true that's not true that's
not true i got a couple fears conan i
mean uh superman has a kryptonite yeah
that was kind of me trying to call
myself invincible yeah uh but here's
what i'm afraid of conan i'll be honest
with you uh when it comes to fighting i
i will fight anybody my fear is fighting
a man while he's naked that's my feeling
um you don't want to fight a naked man
no no no what's the big problem because
when i fight i go low i'm a guy i got to
get you i got to get your legs and my
fear is going to get your legs and
getting hit on the forehead
that's it's a fear like it's it's a real
fear you guys are laughing there's no
way to bounce back from that like no no
no when it hits your head the fight's
over like you literally there's nothing
to do
because you you're going to freak out
i don't want to do anything that i
shouldn't do i don't want to grab stuff
it's just a weird place man what if my
girl's watching what do i say yeah what
do i say why'd you go for his legs i
didn't know what else to do that's what
i always do i always go for his legs
that's a fear of mine i'm sorry so so if
you were attacked by a naked man you
just there'd be no there's nothing else
you could do you just submit you submit
you take it don't say that no no not
submit
[Music]
[Applause]
you just don't want that problem man
because you don't want to get down to a
wrestling to a wrestle off that's my
thing no you don't want that you don't
want that not with the naked dude okay
but you've given you've given anyone who
wanted to beat you up the the key to it
now yeah you're gonna be attacked by
naked men left and right down here you
know what then i deserve to lose that
means that means that god has a message
for me and he wants to talk to me
i don't know either but if naked men
start attacking me there's nothing i can
do all right so okay so you're afraid of
of being attacked by a naked man what
else are you afraid of is there anything
that's that's a little strange or
weirder than that even that that you're
afraid yeah uh uh um
a bum flick in my lip like homeless
people i think a bum a bum yeah a bum a
hobo a hobo a [ __ ] a a guy with dirty
hands that lives on the street uh i'm
afraid of a guy like that clicking my
lips what
the [ __ ] you're afraid of a guy flicking
with dirty hands flicking your legs
you're not thinking about the
consequences okay listen listen to me
for a second just people hear me out
okay for a second okay
the inside of your lip is a prized
possession to you now if somebody
touches that and somebody touches the
inside of your lip what do you do once
again it's just like getting hit in the
head with the thing it's over conan
there's nothing you can do you got to
get a new lip do you know where to get
new lips from because i don't i don't
know where you can buy a new lipstick
wait a minute i'm with you one that i
don't want to get that in the head
either
again
it was college
we were all trying stuff
but the point is
but the lit thing i don't understand if
a stranger comes up to you yeah okay i
need money i say hey conan give me a
dollar you say what uh i gotta die
what are you gonna do what do you do i
don't know exactly okay that's where my
fear comes in i don't want to be the guy
like this after that happens and then he
runs off not with no money but with my
lip he's got a he's got my lip touch now
wait a minute wait a minute that's such
a specific crazy fear okay you see
you're thinking about it touch that okay
no no no no no no go at it no
no
i'm not supposed to know what that looks
like
i want my lip flick man i'm sorry that's
how i feel people
you want to know me there you got it
those are my secrets okay you're very
honest i'll give you that you're very
honest and a little strange